Wow you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
it's Monday night
[Music]
it was a night to watch the church is
the night outside leaf of it so that's
the uncle Joey here why y'all lately you
said like you sit like I'm a carpenter
[Music]
surgeons
[Music]
welcome to mystery pita [ __ ] you
never know what's cracking he on a
Monday night free church with my brother
Lisa at we got all the goodies tonight
please right here we're going deeper
than deep tonight you understand me a
lot of times we tell you we're going
deep tonight we're going under the
[ __ ] murky waters we got a new bar
they stole our second bar the third
one's a [ __ ] charm what do you guys
do we got stars we got [ __ ] toffee
we're burning [ __ ] we don't give a [ __ ]
you going broke tonight [ __ ] we
got this reef with that so [ __ ] good
it's got Poe nails in it it's got
[ __ ] penny dust it's got copper we
got everything this don't give you
cancer
nothing will you know I'm saying we got
cat hairs in this [ __ ] that's
perfect smoke it
let's give the allergies its flavor it's
like it's like it's like [ __ ] hit
everytime you lick in this way
we're
[Music]
that's the one that's the one we saying
that's the one that's the one like a
[ __ ]
oh yeah like a [ __ ] that's the
one that killed Jesus that's the [ __ ]
Jack I'm telling you this we've briefed
of fell in my drawer with everything
everything was in there you understand
me more sugar the juice pumping
everything and I scraped it back up you
know why cuz I'm a soldier when I
dropped an ice cream cone I picked that
mother [ __ ] up and ate it [ __ ] the
germs I kissed them up to Jesus I told
you we're going tonight better they just
[ __ ] shot but over the years I can't
do cardio I can do the elliptical for
like 50 minutes but I can't do jujitsu
I'm gonna ten [ __ ] minutes oh you
following my long as a shot only by
night you'll be fine with another one
blown up for your record
[Music]
you better run right now [ __ ] run
why you got this shot right now Lee I've
been telling you for weeks
run relocate it ain't gonna get no
easier we're going deeper by the [ __ ]
weekend call the feds on a witness for
protection plan few stars Joey be is
protection plan you don't want to do it
almost ours they keep calling you at
night here we go Lisa round two
we got getting some of our hits before
the [ __ ] stars is that them but could
you stop rubbing you have anything gonna
happen no yes
[Music]
[Music]
it's all for the deck people like me let
me help somebody you got some more okay
little bills the car the old my sharing
okay please go right to that second hit
right there see see what it brighten up
there that's the [ __ ] right there
[Music]
tremendous tremendous bong hit [ __ ]
training right here daily on the church
channel we wanna be a good bong hit it
you got a [ __ ] train [ __ ]
you got a train like a bomb Heather you
understand
[Music]
[ __ ] stock better burn Hollywood
burn baby
[Music]
who you think you're dealing with huh I
make it tone in I make it torn in two
you could tune the [ __ ] out in the world
this is as good as it gets [ __ ]
uncle Joey Lisa at the Jews and the
Cubans meeting forming a bond worldwide
with you [ __ ] smoking reefer
who's better than us
[ __ ] the United Nations this is better a
Jew and a Cuban spreading love
throughout the [ __ ] world you
understand me to periscope
you gotta thank periscope - there's no
[ __ ] victim in this this bong is hard
day something right here
something's not right that's got to take
something it should be a lot easier for
me I'm sucking my [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
boiling this thing like a hook on 42nd
[Music]
tremendous I'm glad you brought up the
stars of Dexter's we're going to eat
tonight 200 milligrams they just
breaking them in half which that's it
why [ __ ] around wife beat around the
bush
mmm whatever they're [ __ ] in here we
just yeah that's it we're just gonna eat
this in half tonight we're going deeper
than deep into the murky waters or the
other we're gonna open up with five of
them I see we got left over you're gonna
put a thousand milligrams on a Monday
that's what that's what Mondays or 4000
milligram Mondays okay we got a thousand
milligrams see we're gonna chop up
tonight so we're going 15 I guess how
much you want never to refute what are
you [ __ ] nuts or what BAM two three
like the [ __ ] vampire on Sesame
Street you understand me
one two three Lee don't we put them in
your pockets silence the homeless people
and [ __ ] later he gets into this a
little little lady at 7-eleven loosing a
[ __ ] billy goat we left the lights on
one night she's like shut the [ __ ]
lights out get the [ __ ] outta here
tremendous I counted these thoughts well
I'll give you this one still this
just for good habits you say your good
boy cuz I got a couple of wings out of
myself I never want to leave you because
[ __ ] mafia
I'm trying to do my thing here people
it's a [ __ ] Monday if you ain't
coming out of the [ __ ] gate swinging
go [ __ ] your mother you understand me
there's the Church of what's happening
now it's not a church it's a state of
[ __ ] money burning fire just like
that
you understand me a thousand milligrams
off the bat who's going out who's doing
this [ __ ] out there TV land
I'm watching you leave a little Jew
fingers
[Music]
are you [ __ ] getting me a one big you
think I'd do this podcast Brentley cyan
on to waste your [ __ ] time you think
I'm only these people it's gonna waste
your [ __ ] time I'm gonna report the
news I'm gonna report what's in my heart
and somewhere along the line we'll get a
[ __ ] podcast cookie why cuz that's
how we roll
don't be doing this at home youngsters
don't do this [ __ ] at home [ __ ]
you gotta train yourself up to this [ __ ]
it's been years in the trenches eatin
stars [ __ ] and whatever else you can
[ __ ] eat and it builds your resistance
your tolerance
[Music]
I don't know what the [ __ ] is wrong with
this bum they can blow through it
mmm what the [ __ ] inch we need to take a
[ __ ] hold it
we're packing some reefer [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] this little hole is too [ __ ]
small for us on this side
[Music]
I mean I'm getting something well they
ended up pilot to Bombardier pilot to
Bombardier we want more [ __ ] smoke
here you like that little rhyme pilot to
Bombardier we want more smoke here what
cooks like gas like that thousand
milligrams and numerous buckets since
this [ __ ] morning boo-boo
your uncle Joey that's who you know why
because I'm here to bust down the
stereotypes what you can and cannot do
that's what I'm talking to or you can't
suffice
when people say you can't do it we do it
just to show these [ __ ] who's
running things now Joanie enough with
the chitty-chat it no disrespect load up
that bottle while shut you to [ __ ] off
say no more [ __ ] here we are
always for you guys the church with the
[ __ ] bull and right here but I forgot
to bring you the ball somebody gave us
two hits of [ __ ] asses [ __ ]
Oklahoma in a cigar with a joint with
this [ __ ] asset in the tip nobody
could detect it
not even uncle Joey that's how [ __ ]
slick people don't belong they sold my
[ __ ] shout out see out there in
Oklahoma doing things the right [ __ ]
way
should we think that liquid tonight
leave just a balance of thousands
I don't give a [ __ ] look shits bouncin
did you see me concerns here's how we do
it ladies and gentlemen either you're in
or you're [ __ ] up
[Music]
where's uncle Joey he disappeared in a
cloud of smoke why this what the [ __ ] me
I'm happier till then I'm happy you're
having a [ __ ] good time we got one
more something left on this cut this is
1983's back Bennett ah crimes of passion
well the greatest sounds of 1983 which
is 33 [ __ ] years ago but nothing good
comes out the top this type of [ __ ]
this one she was hungry still in [ __ ]
her and her husband second [ __ ] album
are you kidding me or what side a is the
side of [ __ ] death treat me right
[ __ ] closes up with hell is for
[ __ ] children you can't lose
[ __ ]
but enough is enough what is the record
I love Joey do that believe I only want
to call Natalie he's been eating blue
apron he's on a special [ __ ] low-carb
diet you give him a thousand milligrams
he might [ __ ] go off plus we might
[ __ ] have to do a little liquid drop
acid just to get the blood going it's
Tuesday it's Monday night I'm in then
how can you go to Denver if you're not
[ __ ] in training you understand me
those are professionals out there
I had a will hand-to-hand combat with
those [ __ ] bleeped you ready for a
bunk and let's do this [ __ ] such a mess
such a [ __ ] little mess-up but here
we are on Monday night like family
smoking dope together having a good old
[ __ ] jolly like I tell you you wanna
go to a foreign jump up and down that's
your [ __ ] business me you come over
there now we'll stop a few bong hits
like gentlemen drink some [ __ ] water
whatever the [ __ ] you wanna drink and
we'll just pop that's better than me
than anything else and it always has
been for the last [ __ ] 30 years get
along the way you do a couple bumps you
the quaalude [ __ ] out
sorry the cameraman slipped me get it
together concert
[Music]
your daddy's good girl now look at me
looking good tonight though let so much
Ken here we'll take another that's good
to kiss like it's good alright makes the
weed last long it's like [ __ ]
drinking mango juice to him
[Music]
delicious that [ __ ] you
understand me listen if you're gonna
live live it's not waiting I have
[ __ ] stories everybody says gentlemen
you got a thousand story why because I
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
listen it's downhill you take
rollerskates let's it
who needs brakes who needs brakes when
you got [ __ ] at heart [ __ ]
visit the Pat Benatar hell is for
children [ __ ] do it
spark that [ __ ]
[Music]
guys you know
[Music]
chilling relaxin with my [ __ ] family
here getting ready for the podcast that
our guest is stuck in traffic but want
to keep the train rolling anyway what's
the [ __ ] YouTube channel [ __ ]
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz that's
right [ __ ] get on that [ __ ]
and we'll be rocking your world tonight
you don't need Dancing with the Stars
you don't need Rizzoli & Isles
you don't need none of that [ __ ] you got
your uncle flavor and it's [ __ ] boom
ba Li no I know are you [ __ ] nuts
training training Denver don't forget
about me [ __ ] I want to see a
line out there I wanna see everybody
with a joint they're [ __ ] in if not
don't show up I don't want no Christians
down there I don't want no martyrs down
there couple Jews no sandals though no
hummus eaters no hummus dicks none of
you [ __ ] straight-up [ __ ]
savages of death what qualifies you as a
savage go to page 33 of the church
manual and I'll tell you all the
information all right we'll be back in
ten minutes I love you [ __ ] stay
black